all right so you have two boys eleven
and seven that's a lot of boys in the
house I only have one and that's a lot
so you grew up with women though right
yeah just sisters just sisters and just
female cousins as well like it's just a
world of estrogen yeah God was just
placing a challenge before you yeah well
I don't know why I always knew I was
gonna have boys oh yeah yeah because I
couldn't deal with girls drama ever yeah
never not even when I was a young
teenage girl I know a couple guys that
are just yeah chickens they're hens yeah
yeah you've made a very good point there
yeah I was like I know a lot of guys
that are hens that like to stir a pot I
don't know if this is true but I have to
say even as a girl I thought that boys
at this age like 11 and seven yeah
especially 11 Middle School were so
weird I couldn't understand them for the
life of me and as a mom now strange
though strange yeah and as a mom now I'm
like I still don't understand yeah I
don't know what's going on here I don't
understand the noises coming out of your
mouth my son is Max from wild things
like he's that character my oldest yeah
is like that as well yeah and he has
this he makes up weird sayings and
sounds they just says them over and over
like he's got this one where he goes
this was younger brother I'm sorry for
touching your bum bum
they love my son is just like poop I
think and I'm like oh yep okay like it's
like they get he just like loves weird
words like that but you're like it's not
really funny but I'll laugh with you for
your sake yeah again I'm having to teach
you what the girl's gonna do on the date
to pretend like you're funny exactly
it's like anyway my son is sick so what
do I have to look forward to he's
already a little strange in an awesome
way like I haven't gotten into like boy
like Bo yet yeah you've gotten into that
no just a little tiny touch not so much
although the girls his age aren't
smelling so good yeah well yeah that
happens they've gone there yeah you do
have to look forward to him thinking you
are not cool and be your worst critic so
that is definitely that's already
happening well well done well done is
Advanced yes exactly yeah he sometimes
it's like every once in a while I'll do
something really cool or if I know
someone like I know like I've met Owen
from Jurassic world and he's like yeah
that's like his favorite now yeah I
thought I might be in once I became an
Avenger yeah and then
well he can always find the way that I
am not cool like these are high stakes I
know he was like Mom why do you have to
be the worst Avenger
[Music]
yeah that helps but then now with
Quantum Mania I've sort of graduated to
being like a senior Avenger and he's
like okay Mom now you're cool
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]